.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Mir gefällt
das französische Savoir-vivre
und auch die Franzosen.
Das ist sicher etwas,
das uns kompatibel macht.
Wenn meine Frau weg ist,
vermisse ich sie sehr.
Nur nahe bei ihr
bin ich überglücklich.
Ich mache dich glücklich?
- Ja, genau.
Ja.
Wenn es für dich irgendwann
nicht mehr funktionieren würde,
hätten wir keinen Plan B.
Wenigstens ich nicht.
Das sind wir. Ja.
* Romantische Ballade *
Zwei Länder, eine Liebe -
das ist "Hin und weg".
Es ist 6 Uhr morgens.
5 Min.
- Okay.
Monica Peter Artawan steht
ein intensiver Arbeitstag bevor.
Ihr Mann Dewa unterstützt sie.
So.
Ich muss noch etwas fertig machen,
dann haben wir das auch.
Der 38-Jährige
ist praktizierender Hindu,
wie die meisten Menschen auf Bali.
Bevor wir losfahren, mache ich das.
Es ist wie eine Absicherung
durch die Götter,
damit wir keinen Unfall haben.
Darum bringen wir
immer erst Opfergaben dar.
De? Bist du bereit?
Ja.
Weil auf Bali nur Paare mit
derselben Religion heiraten dürfen,
konvertierte Monica
vor elf Jahren zum Hinduismus.
Kommst du auch?
* Mystische Klänge *
Die Regeln des Hinduismus
sind so komplex ...
Das Wichtige ist,
dass es von Herzen kommt
und man mit dem Herzen betet.
Dann ist ein Fehler verzeihbar.
Es ist ein Schritt, um zu lernen.
Doch auch nach vielen Jahren auf Bali
gibt es für die 58-Jährige
noch Fallstricke.
Kommt das hinten rein?
Z.B. was in den Gebetsraum
gehört und was nicht.
Ich platzierte das
irgendwo relativ hoch.
Dewa sah das und sagte: "Wer
hat das gemacht? Das geht nicht."
Und ich: "Wieso?"
"Du weisst doch, das ist hoch oben."
Bei den Hindus ist der Kopf
und alles, was hoch oben ist,
nahe mit den Göttern verbunden.
Und ich habe etwas Dreckiges
sehr weit oben platziert.
Das war sehr falsch.
Das kommt mir immer in den Sinn,
wenn ich Handtücher sehe.
Dewa
fährt seine Frau zum ersten Meeting.
In der Stadt
herrscht bereits dichter Verkehr.
Monica hat ein Treffen
mit einem Auftraggeber
in einem Hotel auf dem Land.
Tschüss, bis heute Abend. Tschau.
- Tschüss.
Hoi, Ueli. Hallo.
So, gehen wir rein?
- Ja.
Der Schweizer Ueli Wick ist Unter-
nehmer und stellt Luxuszelte her.
Vor acht Jahren
stattete er dieses Hotel damit aus.
Hello.
* Sie sprechen balinesisch. *
Er hat den schönen Boden gemacht.
- Ja.
Und all diese Details.
Das macht es natürlich aus.- Toll.
Man könnte das eine oder andere
noch gastfreundlicher machen.
Das Hotel liegt mitten im Dschungel.
Luftfeuchtigkeit und Hitze
haben den Zelten zugesetzt.
Hier findet dich niemand,
wenn du nicht willst.- Der Bambus.
Und dieser Farnbaum - unglaublich.
- Da muss man auch was machen.
Unbedingt. Das ist zerfressen.
Die Inneneinrichterin
bekommt von Ueli den Auftrag,
die Ausstattung zu erneuern.
Wir müssen etwas
mit den Lampen machen.
Das sehe ich. Genau.
Die sind ca. acht Jahre alt.
- Ja, klar.
Was ich nicht weiss ...
Mir wären ...
Die kleinen Stühle
neben dem Bett ...
Vielleicht könnte man
richtige bedside tables machen.
Ich finde, es hat
drei zu grosse items in dieser Ecke.
So.
Ja, das sollte gut sein.
Ich bin sehr detailorientiert.
Ich weiss, dass die Details
es schlussendlich ausmachen.
Es gibt nicht viele, die das
hier schon von Anfang an haben.
Ich versuche, ihnen das
auf eine gute Art beizubringen
und das Warum zu erklären.
Das macht die Arbeit
auch wertvoller.
Die Schweizer Tugenden
haben in Asien schon einen Vorteil.
Dewa ist mit Monica vor einem halben
Jahr aus der Schweiz zurückgekehrt.
Mit der Stellensuche als Koch
lässt er sich Zeit.
Darum kann er sich
einen alten Wunsch erfüllen:
Er nimmt Lektionen in Tempeltanz
bei einem bekannten Meister.
Das erde ihn und bringe ihn
den Göttern nah, sagt er.
* Rhythmische Trommel *
* Balinesische Musik *
* Unverständliche Anweisungen *
Mir gefällt die Ruhe
und Ausstrahlung, diese Aura.
Das gibt mir das Gefühl,
er sei mein Fels in der Brandung.
Er ruht so in sich.
Dass der Meister seinem Schüler
Kostüm und Maske leiht,
ist eine grosse Ehre.
Doch beides ist Dewa zu eng.
Hier kann ich sehen. Hier nicht.
* Balinesische Musik *
Für Dewa ist die Welt voller Götter.
Sie bestimmen das Schicksal.
Dass seine Frau den Glauben teilt,
verbindet die beiden.
* Applaus *
Es ist wunderbar. Ein Segen.
Es ist das erste Mal mit Maske.
Das war unglaublich.
Man muss sich
mit den Göttern verbinden,
dann bewegt man sich
wie in einer Meditation.
Beim Tanzen ist der Kragen schwer,
aber ich habe vergessen,
den leichten Sarong zu heben.
Die Fernbeziehung war für mich
eine Zwischenlösung
für etwas Dauerhaftes.
Ich bin nicht sicher,
ob ich das noch einmal machen würde.
Nein, wieso auch?
Das klingt so,
als ob es das ... nicht wert war.
Doch, das war es.
Darum will ich es bewahren.
Ich will das
nicht noch einmal durchmachen.
Das musst du jetzt sagen, sonst
gibt es kein Abendessen.- Genau.
In der Provinz Smaland,
auf halbem Weg
zwischen Göteborg und Stockholm,
baute Niklas für Florence ein Haus.
Vor eineinhalb Jahren
zogen sie und neun Hunde zusammen.
Hallo.
- Hi.
So.
Sie hatten tatsächlich Brot.
- Ja, das ist normal.
Endlich habe ich gutes gefunden.
Schau, was ich dir gekauft habe.
Semla!
- Ja.
Das ist typisch schwedisch.
Ja.
Haben wir diese grossen Pflaster?
Ja, warte kurz.
Ich will dir nicht wehtun. Okay.
Wie heisst das? Blinddarm?
- Ja, auf Deutsch Blinddarm.
In Schwedisch auch.
Es war eine Blinddarmentzündung.
Sie machten
sofort eine Notoperation.
Im Scan haben sie gesehen,
dass es schlimm ist.
Sie sagten: "Wir machen zwei,
drei Löchlein und nehmen ihn raus."
Und mit dieser Narbe
bin ich aufgewacht.
Sie sagten, er habe sich versteckt.
Ich bin gottenfroh,
dass wir uns durchsetzen konnten
und sie die Bildgebung machten.
Sie hätten ihn nach Hause geschickt.
Damals war Winter, es hatte Schnee,
es dauert jedes Mal 1 Std. ...
Ja ...
Das ist nicht so lustig.
Man hat die Horrorszenarien im Kopf.
Aber gut,
dass sie es machen konnten.
Ja.
Wir sind verwöhnt
mit dem Schweizer Gesundheitssystem.
Es läuft hier halt wirklich anders.
Niklas
hat die Operation schwer zugesetzt.
Möchtest du
das andere Kissen für die Beine?
Nein, ist okay.
Der 50-Jährige
hat viel Gewicht verloren.
Normalerweise ist er aktiv
und arbeitet im eigenen KMU.
Ich liege hier und mache nichts.
Vielleicht gibt es News -
nach 10 Min.
Du musst immer pinkeln.
So.
Max ist abgehauen!
- Oh!
Max, du bist ein Trottel.
* Pfeifen *
Du bist ein Frechdachs. Ah. Aha.
Du.
Er war sicher mit der Pfote dran.
Alles ist gefroren
und hier ist es weg.
Da muss ich basteln gehen.
Er denkt, er habe immer recht.
Ich sage dann, "Du hast recht",
und denke, "Romain, was soll's".
Ja, ich bin nicht einverstanden.
Das ist genau wie ...
Mit dem, was er gerade gesagt hat,
verweigert er mir,
dass ich davon lernen kann.
Finde ich.
Ich lerne nichts,
wenn du das so machst.
Ich will dich nicht belehren.
- Wir sind zusammen, eine Familie.
Du musst das ändern.
- Ich bin nicht dein Lehrer.
Aber wir müssen damit klarkommen.
* Jamal stottert. *
Es gibt noch viel zu tun.
* Entspannte Musik *
In Montreal stehen Jamal und Romain
vor einer grossen Veränderung.
In acht Wochen
wird ihr Leihmutterbaby geboren.
Dann sind sie zu dritt.
Das gefällt mir nicht.
Die Punkte?
- Je n'aime pas.
Magst du das?
Ist das da,
um ein Kind anzuschnallen?
Nein, für irgendwas.
- Doch, um das Kind anzuschnallen.
Das ist nicht schön.
- Das lässt sich heben.
Viele Bekannte sagten:
"Ihr könnt alles bereit haben,
aber am Schluss
wechselt ihr die Windeln am Boden."
Ganz sicher nicht.
Nicht in Frankreich.
Ich weiss nicht wo,
aber bestimmt nicht auf dem Boden.
Sicher. On prend un truc comme ça.
Das Bett haben wir schon gekauft.
So die grossen Sachen, von denen
man weiss, dass man sie braucht.
Aber wenn es
um die praktischen Dinge geht,
und wir uns fragen,
wie wir das machen ...
Wir haben beide eine Vorstellung,
aber keine Ahnung, ob es so ist.
Da überlegt man sich schon, dass wir
in zwei Monaten hier wickeln.
Hm?
- Das gefällt mir, aber das nicht.
Oui.
Ich weiss nicht.
Glas könnte zerbrechen.
Aber ...
Nein, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Was ist das da?
Das ist
eine elektronische Brustpumpe.
Nein, das brauchen wir nicht.
Je pense que
ça seraient les truc normales.
Ein Männerpaar mit einem Baby ist
in Kanada nichts Aussergewöhnliches.
Leihmutterschaft ist hier
seit knapp 20 Jahren erlaubt.
Wenn man in einen Babyladen geht,
ist das einfach normal.
Da schaut dich niemand komisch an
und fragt sich: "Wo ist die Frau?"
Es ist klar, dass wir ein Kind haben
und es so ist.
Ich bin sehr froh,
diese Chance zu bekommen.
Ich hatte es eigentlich
schon fast abgehakt,
aber hier ist das jetzt möglich.
Sind sie bei uns registriert?
- (Beide) Nein.
Noch nicht.
Machen wir das?
Wir kommen jetzt bestimmt häufiger.
Möchten sie ein Konto?
- (Beide) Ja, danke.
(Beide) Merci.
* Entspannte Musik *
Für ihr Baby wählten Jamal und Romain
vor sieben Monaten
eine Eizellenspenderin aus.
Mithilfe eines Katalogs.
Wir haben sie nach
Augen- und Hautfarbe ausgewählt.
Ich fand das sehr natürlich.
Wie im normalen Leben,
wenn man jemanden sucht und sich
auf den ersten Blick verliebt.
Wieso sollten wir
die genetische Mutter unseres Kindes
nicht über ein Foto auswählen?
Die
mit Jamals Samen befruchtete Eizelle
wurde Leihmutter Ashley eingepflanzt.
Ashley ist genetisch
mit dem Kind nicht verwandt.
Ihr werden nur
die medizinischen Kosten abgegolten.
Das ist das erste Ultraschallbild,
das wir erhalten haben.
Im Wartesaal
hatte es sehr viele Leute.
Und wir lernten uns dort kennen
und erzählten, wer wir sind.
Gleichzeitig
hatte sie schon unser Kind im Bauch.
Das war speziell.
Aber als ich
beim Ultraschall dabei sein konnte
und unser Baby zum ersten Mal sah
und wir den Herzschlag hörten -
das war sehr eindrücklich.
Ich habe Romain über FaceTime
angerufen und zeigte es ihm.
Es war schön,
dass wir das machen konnten.
Wir fragten Ashley,
wieso sie das mache, und sie meinte,
ein eigenes Kind zu haben
sei das grösste Glück.
Ihres ist jetzt 14-jährig.
Sie findet den Moment grossartig,
wo sie das Kind
den Eltern übergeben kann.
Und ich glaube fast,
sie mag es, schwanger zu sein.
Ich kann mir hier sicher sein,
dass es nicht
um die Ausbeutung einer Frau geht.
Es ist schon eine Sicherheit,
dass die Frauen
das aus dem richtigen Grund machen.
En anglais?
- Oui.
Ashley fragt soeben:
"Was, wenn ihr es nicht rechtzeitig
zur Geburt schafft?"
Das ist schon zweimal passiert.
In Bali ist es easy-peasy.
Hier läuft das so. Völlig anders.
Come on, it's not always easy-peasy.
Zeitmässig arbeiten wir
fast gleich viel wie in der Schweiz,
aber es ist gemütlicher,
weil es nicht so einen ...
Der Zeitdruck ist schon da, aber
die Hektik nicht, sagen wir es so.
In der Schweiz
ist es immer stressig.
Nach dem Tempeltanz will sich Dewa
eine eigene Maske anfertigen lassen.
Ein Priester bittet die Götter
um die richtige Wahl des Holzes
und um Inspiration.
I Wayan Muka ist der berühmteste
Maskenschnitzer auf Bali.
Die Maske ist eine Massanfertigung.
Das richtige Holz und
die richtige Grösse sind wichtig.
Die Maske behält man
sein ganzes Leben. Für immer.
Später
gibt man sie in der Familie weiter.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Hi Anvi, danke fürs Kommen.
Monica stellt ihre neue Kreation vor.
Wir haben wieder unsere Zelte
und die Outdoormöbel.
Die Brandmanagerin
beurteilt Monicas Vorschlag.
Wir haben Tische aus Teak
und diese Kacheln.
Beautiful.
- Die stammt aus Sidemen in Bali.
Eine kunstvoll gefertigte Kachel
aus Bali.
Die Linie
soll weltweit verkauft werden.
Anvi,
was meinst du zum Fotoshooting?
Josh hat gerade gefragt,
ob wir es mit Personen machen sollen
oder nur die Einrichtung?
Erst machen wir es
nur mit den Produkten.
Für ein zweites Shooting
können wir Influencer einladen,
die das für uns machen.
* Entspannte Musik *
1 Std. Autofahrt entfernt
ist die Manufaktur,
welche die Plättchen anfertigt.
Hey, da sind wir.
Die Herstellung ist aufwendig:
Jede Farbe wird einzeln in die Form
gegossen und mit Sand gepresst.
Das erste Plättchen ist geboren.
Wunderschön. Vielen Dank.
Sie machen das sehr geschickt, Ibu.
Yeah.
Jetzt kriegt das ganze Produkt
langsam Leben.
Das war lange hier oben im Kopf
und jetzt beginnt es zu leben.
Ich habe Gänsehaut.
Das nennen wir Adajinta.
- Ja.
Mit Liebe gemacht.
Ja,
ohne Liebe ist alles nichts wert.
Diese einfache Küche
gehört Dewas Tante.
Bei seinem Besuch
lässt er es sich nicht nehmen,
ihre Familie zu bekochen.
Monica kommt dazu.
Sie wird Ibu Jero genannt
und ist ein gern gesehener Gast.
Dewa hat in der Schweiz
in erstklassigen Häusern gekocht,
aber sein Herz hängt
an den einfachen Speisen von hier.
In Zürich war alles ganz anders.
Alles war elektrisch,
die Küche vom Feinsten.
Hier
kocht man auf kleinen Gaskochern.
In Zürich
war ich am Anfang total verwirrt.
Als Monika hier
zum ersten Mal zu Besuch war,
war vieles neu für sie.
Nasi Goreng ...
Darf ich dir davon geben?
- Genug, genug, nur weisser Reis.
Das reicht. Danke.
Es ist ungewohnt,
weil man oft von Hand isst
und wir sind uns vom Auge her
eine andere Präsentation gewohnt.
Man muss extrem offen sein
und Vertrauen haben.
Aber das geht sehr schnell
und es ist auch sehr lecker.
* Entspannte Musik *
Du bist verantwortlich,
dass ich mich wohlfühle?
Ja, manchmal schon.
Das möchte ich nicht.
- Nein, natürlich nicht.
Aber du hast deine Heimat, deine
Mutter und deine Töchter verlassen.
Du hast viel aufgegeben,
um hier zu leben.
Wir haben diese Entscheidung
gemeinsam getroffen.
Es kann halt
nicht immer alles "juhui" sein.
Niklas muss das Bett hüten.
Ausreisser Max ist zurück.
Ja, wegen dir, Max.
Alles nur wegen dir.
Wenn Florence
eine erneute Flucht verhindern will,
muss sie selbst anpacken.
Wenn Niklas fit wäre,
würde ich einfach sagen: "Honey ..."
* Entspannte Musik *
Ich muss doch noch Niklas holen.
In der nahe gelegenen Stadt Jönköping
führt Niklas eine Glaserei.
Bevor Florence in sein Leben trat,
war er begeisterter Bergsteiger.
Die beiden haben sich vor fünf Jahren
auf Facebook kennengelernt.
Niklas suchte eine Übersetzerin.
Daraus
wurde eine dreijährige Fernbeziehung.
Du siehst toll aus.
War die Reise okay?
- Ja.
Look.
Mitten in einem Wald in Südschweden
baute Niklas für seine grosse Liebe
und ihre neun Hunde ein Haus.
Dein neues Zuhause.
Die Hundedusche.
- Darum liebt sie mich.
Weil ich so was mache.
- Ja, darum liebe ich dich.
Bereits nach einem Jahr
haben sie geheiratet
und wollten
in Schweden zusammenziehen.
Aber Corona machte
einen Strich durch die Rechnung.
Wir gewöhnen uns nie daran.
- Nein, das ist immer schlimm.
Es ist Scheisse, Adieu zu sagen.
Bye.
In der Schweiz lebte Florence
mit ihren Hunden
mitten in einem Wohnquartier.
Das gefiel
nicht allen in der Nachbarschaft.
Auch Tochter Noya war bei ihr.
Sie benötigte
viel Zuwendung der Mutter.
Bis heute telefonieren sie täglich.
Hallo.
- Was ist passiert?
Emma hatte vorher einen Anfall.
Sie hat so gezittert.
Sie erbrach die ganze Nacht
und trinkt gar nichts.
Ich habe die Tierklinik angerufen
und kann um 15.30 Uhr vorbeigehen.
Schau mal, wie sie aussieht.
- Oh Emmi, was ist los mit dir?
Also, geh in die Klinik
und ruf mich dann sofort an.
Ist gut. Bis später.
- Ich habe dich lieb. Tschüss.
Bis heute schmerzt Florence
die Trennung von ihrer Tochter.
Ja ... Es ist nicht einfach.
Nein.
Gerade als Mutter macht man sich
wahnsinnige Schuldgefühle.
Ist es dem Kind gegenüber
egoistisch? Ist das richtig?
Auch wenn sie 20 ist und jetzt
mit ihrem Freund zusammenwohnt ...
Es tut weh.
Brauchst du noch etwas?
- Nein, nein.
Ich würde sagen, zweimal pro Jahr
gab es einen grossen Streit.
Es ging immer um Zeit etc.
Als ich zum ersten Mal seine
ganze Familie kennenlernen sollte,
waren wir
um 11 Uhr zum Brunch verabredet.
Das GPS sagte: Ankunft 11.02 Uhr.
Wir rasten, auf der Autobahn
wurde ich ständig geblitzt,
die Bussen
haben mich 2'000 Euro gekostet.
Die Franzosen übertreiben.
Um 11.02 Uhr stiegen wir aus.
Die ganze Familie sass da
mit der Gabel in der Hand,
weil man um 11 Uhr zu Essen beginnt.
In diesem Moment begriff ich:
Es liegt nicht an Jamal.
Alle Schweizer sind krank,
was die Pünktlichkeit betrifft.
Vor der Geburt des Babys
besucht Jamal seine Mutter Gertrud
in Münchenbuchsee.
Du hast immer gesagt, du seist
ein hässliches Baby gewesen.
Grossvati sagte, ich habe mir
bei dir nicht so Mühe gegeben.
Aber nach sechs Monaten sagte er,
du würdest jeden Tag hübscher.
Und siehst du, was rausgekommen ist?
Schau mal. Das ist doch süss.
Kaffee oder Espresso, Jamal?
Kaffee.
Soll ich den Kuchen schneiden?
- Ja, gerne.
Das habe ich
schon lange nicht mehr gemacht.
Der ist ja schön, Mami. Fantastisch,
der Apfelkuchen.- Nicht wahr?
So gemütlich waren wir zwei
schon lange nicht mehr zusammen.
Nein, nicht so oft.
Ja, es ist sicher ...
Das letzte Mal.
Bald ist immer jemand dabei.- Ja.
Wenn in einem Spital ein Kind durch
Leihmutterschaft zur Welt kommt,
erhält es so ein wrist band.
- Ein Armband.
Mhm. Dort drauf
steht der Nachname der Leihmutter.
Aber auf dem Dokument,
das wir kriegen,
bevor wir das Spital verlassen,
steht dann,
dass das Baby mit ihrem Nachnamen
jetzt so und so heisst
und wir die Väter sind.
Ich kann es mir besser
von ihrer Seite vorstellen
als von der Seite der Leihmutter.
Das ist für mich ...
Ich kann mich da
nicht reinversetzen.
Dass ich das könnte
bzw. dass man das kann.
Aber für sie ist das natürlich toll
und gut, dass man das machen kann.
Ja.
Jamal sagte schon als Junge immer,
er wolle eine Familie.
Und jetzt hat er das
und ist glücklich. Und ich auch.
* Entspannte Musik *
Während
seines zweiwöchigen Schweizbesuchs
wohnt Jamal
bei der Familie seines Bruders.
(TV) For the final team
in this event from Canada ...
Er verfolgt live einen
Eiskunstlauf-Grandprix in Japan.
Sein Mann Romain
hat die kanadischen Paare gecoacht.
Die Führenden
sind auch seine Schüler.
Gold und Silber gibt es sowieso.
Es fragt sich nur noch, wer.
(TV) We'll get the scores.
We'll get the standings.
Season's best with a 210.41 ...
Ja, das ist natürlich schön.
Das macht immer Spass.
Wir sind etwas verwöhnt.
Sie haben dieses Jahr
an den Grandprix
schon ca. zehn Medaillen gewonnen.
Romain hat wieder eine Goldmedaille
gewonnen.- Wirklich?
Gell?
Du kriegst bald
einen Cousin oder eine Cousine.
Bravo, Götti.
- Was, "Bravo"?
Ich war so glücklich,
als sie mich fragten,
ob ich Aiyanas Götti sein wolle.
Ich freute mich natürlich extrem.
Sie ist jetzt vier
und ich durfte miterleben,
wie sie grösser wird.
Und jetzt
kriege ich bald ein eigenes Baby.
Bruder Rahim und seine Frau
haben drei Kinder.
Jamal darf sich ausgiebig bei
den ausgedienten Kleidern bedienen.
Da, da ...
- Windeln?
Ja, eigentlich ...
- Das alles?
Schau,
das ist der absolute Wahnsinn.
Willst du es?
- Vielleicht.
Das ist ein dickes Pyjama.
Ich bin der Kleinste von vier.
Ich habe viel nachgetragen.
Ich finde das auch okay.
Sie wachsen ja sowieso sofort raus.
Das sind Wickelbodys.
Das ist das Beste, ich sage es dir.
Ich sage immer:
"Es gibt über 8 Mrd. Menschen."
"Die haben das alle geschafft. Viele
Trottel haben das hingekriegt."
Also: Easy, es kommt schon gut.
Wenn ich denke,
dass ich es darin einpacke ...
Hm?
In den Mund. In den Mund. Genau.
Macht der Onkel das gut?
Es war nicht
"Päng, du bist es jetzt".
Nein, ich musste kämpfen.
Wieso musste ich um dich kämpfen?
Ich dachte, du liebst mich.
Schritt für Schritt.
Okay.
Ja. Ist das gut?
Gut. Lächle für Daddy.
- Ja.
Ja.
- Ja, so ist fein. Okay.
Didi Kunz lernte Melisa
auf den Philippinen kennen.
Sie ist 26 Jahre jünger als er.
Vor der Heirat
lebten sie in ihrer Heimat zusammen.
Melisa liess ihn
sieben Jahre auf das Jawort warten.
Ich wusste,
dass er ein guter Mann ist.
Ich sah sein Gesicht,
wie er sich bewegte.
Ich beobachtete ihn genau.
Ich weiss,
dass er ein guter Mann ist.
Wir haben jeden Tag
miteinander geflirtet.
Jeden Tag. Das war alles klar.
Und das Lächeln war Nr. 1.
Wenn du eine gute Frau hast,
kann man auch solche Kinder haben.
Das Paar
hat mit den Töchtern Zara und Mayari
während der Coronapandemie
in der Schweiz gelebt.
Didi
arbeitete im Sommer als Bademeister.
Nie hätte er gedacht, dass er
noch eine Familie haben würde.
Denn er, der eine Lehre
als Rheinmatrose gemacht hat,
hatte eigentlich ganz andere Pläne:
Er träumte von einer Weltumsegelung
mit dem eigenen Boot.
Wenn du um die Welt segeln willst,
geht das drei bis fünf Jahre.
Genügend Geld für fünf Jahre
auf der Seite zu haben ...
Ich hatte Freunde,
die auf den Philippinen waren
und mir davon erzählten.
Darum fand ich:
"Okay, ich gehe dort hin."
Nach eineinhalb Jahren
nehmen sie Abschied von der Schweiz
und kehren
auf die Philippinen zurück.
Die Wohnung in St. Gallen
lösen sie auf.
Didi freut sich auf sein anderes
Zuhause, das direkt am Meer liegt.
Ja, ja. Gut. Ja. It's okay.
Das sind meine Winterschuhe.
Die brauche ich jetzt nicht mehr.
Dort, wo wir hingehen,
ist es schön warm.
Dort bin ich nur barfuss unterwegs.
Die beiden haben viel zu tun.
Es ist viel Arbeit.
Aber das ist okay.
Wir müssen viel organisieren:
Die Wohnung muss geräumt werden, die
Kinder von der Schule abgemeldet ...
In diesen drei Säcken
sind alle Rechnungen etc.
der eineinhalb Jahren drin.
Auf den Philippinen
haben wir ein Tor vor dem Haus.
Ende Monat
hängt dort ein Zettel dran:
"Ihre Rechnung für den Strom
ist 25 Fr."
Das ist alles, was ich dort kriege.
Ich habe also
keinen Zettelkrieg mehr.
Ich kann leben.
Grüezi miteinander. So.
- Morgen. Grüezi.
Ich bringe Ihnen gute Sachen.
Der läuft wunderbar.
Den würde ich nach Hause nehmen.
Der ganze Haushalt der Familie
geht zurück ins Brockenhaus.
Hier haben sie damals alles gekauft.
Das ist von der Kommode.
Dort muss noch jemand helfen.
You don't have to do it alone.
Are there any men here?
Runter? Okay. Ay.
Eineinhalb Jahre hatten wir die.
Darauf sass die ganze Familie
und schaute fern.
Ja.
72.70 Fr.
- Okay.
Hast du Geld? Nehmen Sie Karte?
- Ja.
Die sechsjährige Mayari
hat hier Deutsch gelernt.
Jetzt muss sie sich von ihren Kinder-
gartenfreundinnen verabschieden.
Ich bringe dieses Zeug mit.
Das kann so machen.
So eine Blase machen.
Hi, dad.
- Sali, Schätzchen.
Und, wie war es?
- Es war schön.
Meine ganze Klasse hat mir
Abschiedsbriefe geschrieben.- Wow.
Ein ganzer Sack voller Briefe.
"Liebe Zara,
ich wünsche dir von Ganzem
eine erlebnisreiche Reise
in die Philippinen."
"Herzliche Grüsse ..."
Das hat sie sehr schön geschrieben.
- Ja.
Später kannst du ihr
eine E-Mail und Fotos schicken.
"Liebe Grüsse von Mila." Oh, nett.
Wo ist Mayari?
Es ist okay. Du musst nicht weinen.
Ich bin so traurig wegen Elina.
Keine Sorge.
Du kannst mit ihr skypen.
Hm? Do not cry.
Bereits morgen fliegt die ganze
Familie zurück in ihre alte Heimat.
Ich habe mega Hunger.
Vor der Geburt des Babys
geniessen Romain und Jamal
ausgiebig ihre freien Abende.
Ich werde die ganze Karte bestellen.
- Ich sterbe vor Hunger.
Ich liebe es, Freunde zu treffen,
Party zu machen, nicht zu arbeiten
und Zeit für uns zwei zu haben,
ein wenig fernzusehen ...
Wir machen Party,
arbeiten, essen und schlafen.
Ja, wir haben keine Hobbys.
No.
Il a travaillé tard hier.
Je l'ai vu.
In ihrer Lieblingsbar
treffen sie gute Freunde.
Ça va?
- Ça va?
Natürlich geben auch hier
Leihmutterschaft und Baby zu reden.
Für mich wäre das ein Opfer, das ich
nicht bereit bin, zu bringen.
Vieles ist auch unbekannt.
In unserem Freundeskreis
sind sie die Ersten,
die ein solches Projekt haben.
Wir werden sehen, wie das geht.
Klar ist, dass wir sie wohl etwas
weniger im Ausgang treffen werden.
Es ist wunderbar, dass sich meine
Freunde dazu entschlossen haben.
Es inspiriert mich, vielleicht
eines Tages dasselbe zu tun.
Bis dann werde ich sie besuchen.
Und das Baby in meinen Armen halten,
wenn sie es erlauben.
Ich bin noch total beschäftigt:
mitten in der Arbeit,
den Wettkämpfen.
Ich bin aufgeregt, aber ich weiss:
E r  hat Albträume.- Ja.
Was bei uns halt anders ist:
Wir haben unser Leben.
Und dann fahren wir ins Spital,
kriegen ein Kind in die Hände
und kommen damit nach Hause.
Man stellt sich nicht langsam
darauf ein, der Bauch wächst ...
Ein bisschen,
aber es ist nicht dasselbe,
wie wenn man
eine schwangere Frau zu Hause hat.
Ich denke manchmal:
"Wir müssen runterfahren,
und Zeit für uns nehmen,
damit wir nicht aus allen Wolken
fallen, wenn es da ist."
In der nächsten Folge
ist Didi mit seiner Familie
auf den Philippinen angekommen.
Das einfache Leben
erfüllt ihn mit Glück.
You're here. Hast du es probiert?
Das ist gut, oder?
Man könnte den Luxus runterschrauben
und mehr Lebensqualität haben.
In Schweden wird für Florence
das einsame Leben mitten im Wald
zur Belastung.
Nie einen Menschen zu sehen,
fünf Tage in der Woche,
hat schon angefangen,
mir zuzusetzen.
Manchmal fühle ich mich
schon dafür verantwortlich,
dass es ihr gut geht. Somehow.
In Kanada ist er da,
der langersehnte Moment.
1 Std.
- Wir haben die SMS erhalten,
dass das Baby
in 1 Std. auf die Welt kommt.
Jetzt
müssen wir uns auf den Weg machen.
* Romantische Ballade *
Aw.
Jamal,
hast du die Windeln gewechselt?
Ja.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023